dans ce bâtiment leclerc historique de
l'antenne lui en courtoise de
l'université versailles saint quentin en
yvelines
armel le bras chopard ne compte plus les
souvenirs elle l'a vu se construire et
évoluer
et là le plus grand amphi du départ des
souvenirs qui tiennent dans ses journaux
réalisé par les étudiants promotion 1988
on y trouve cette anecdote de la fac
dans un couffin le bâtiment était à
l'origine une école maternelle
c'était drôle parce que les les sièges
étaient tout petits voulu les toilettes
ne permet pas quand l'antenne devient uv
est ce qu elle en est le vice présidente
elle impulse également la création d'une
filière sciences politiques
alors qu'il en existait peu en france
mais dans la vie d'une universitaire il
y a aussi la recherche et les livres
classe est une tous les livres une
partie parce que j'en ai encore en haut
tout ce qui concerne des deux ce qui
concerne les femmes
première femme à avoir obtenu
l'agrégation de sciences politiques elle
consacre sa thèse à pierre leroux
qu'elle considère comme l'inventeur du
socialisme j'ai feuilleté un manuel
d'histoire des idées politiques et la
page s'est arrêté à pierre l'euro et
alors je lis qu'on
l'auteur du manuel disait ce que cet
auteur est complètement fou sa pensée
rocambolesque etc et je me suis dit
c'est pour moi
pierre leroux est aussi le premier
député à avoir parlé du droit de vote
pour les femmes à l'assemblée en 1848
les femmes et les inégalités de genre
traverse les travaux d'armel le bras
chopard des travaux qui lui valent des
reconnaissances pour le zoo des
philosophes
elle obtient le prix médicis catégorie
et c'est une surprise et alors j'avais
une nuée de journalistes autour de moi
alors comment kss kss kss kss qu'il ya
dans ce livre etc
et je me souviens que j'étais tellement
abrutis que j'avais produit pas je ne
sais pas après ce livre elle se consacre
pleinement à une nouvelle mission
elle est appelée au ministère de
l'éducation nationale pour travailler
sur l'égalité des chances femmes hommes
dans l'enseignement supérieur depuis les
universités sont toutes dotées de chargé
de mission égalité femmes-hommes
ou comment transformer la théorie en
pratique avec ses livres elle espère
apporter sa petite contribution à une
prise de conscience plus générale et
c'est très difficile de faire comprendre
que le féminisme c'est par la prise du
pouvoir par les femmes c'est la place
des femmes à égalité avec des hommes le
ministre cdh une idée de du
d'harmonieuses mixité si les bancs des
amphithéâtres lui manque
elle n'arrête pas l'écriture et la
recherche son dernier livre les
pérégrinations des compagnons de la
femme est sortie il ya quelques semaines
les recherches pour le prochain sont
déjà fait un retour sur pierre leroux et
sa lutte pour défendre le droit de vote
des femmes